hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video seht schon im titel eingeblendet
eine wichtige änderung ist eigentlich
gar nicht mal so unfassbar krass erstmal
wir befinden uns hier natürlich wieder
in der minecraft beta version und zocken
hier wieder unser let's play weiter was
erstmal die große wichtige änderung ist
deswegen wahrscheinlich auch sehr viele
das video angeklickt haben dieses let's
play wird ab jetzt uncut weiter gehen
also ab dem zeitpunkt wo ich gleich
irgendwie sage so hay ab jetzt an kann
aber erstmal rede ich noch kurz nein
eigentlich rede ich gar nicht mehr kurz
also dass let's play hier geht ab jetzt
uncut weiter und warum ich mich dafür
entschieden habe und alles andere warum
auch gestern kein video kam kommt jetzt
quasi ab jetzt uncut ich wollte das
ganze einfach mal testen weil mich sehr
viele leute angeschrieben haben
von wegen luca irgendwie auch wenn du
jetzt damals mal gesagt hast ja wir
haben hier da an let's play und hier
letztlich du hast immer alles
geschnitten macht auch mal einfach
wieder so ein bisschen wo man überhaupt
nicht sieht ist überhaupt nicht
geschnitten hast und ich hab das ja auch
ein paar mal versucht so ich muss mir
jetzt auch erstmal wieder daran gewöhnen
hier so ein bisschen kohle darin ja ich
hab ihn okay das schön
ich musste daran erst mal so ein
bisschen gewöhnen weil ich so was wie
gesagt eine zeitlang mal probiert haben
nach dem motto ok ich probiere jetzt mal
das ganze anker zumachen und hab das
auch eigentlich mehr oder weniger
hingekriegt allerdings habe ich immer
noch zwischendurch einen parkplatz
gesetzt einfach weil ich ich sage mal
nicht weggekommen bin von dem schneiden
das hört sich bescheuert an
ich weiß auch dass sie sich komplett
bescheuert anhört allerdings ist es halt
einfach so wenn man einmal da drin ist
von wegen okay ich schneide dann atmet
man bei einer aufnahme ganz anders man
redet komplett anders es ist echt alles
komplett anders ist hört sich jetzt
wahrscheinlich die meisten sagen sich
wahrscheinlich eh grad wieder so a
der rabatt crêpes das stimmt gar nicht
als wenn man an das atmen wenn man nicht
schneidet oder so nee das ist schon die
wahrheit wenn ich eine hinschmeißen
münchen nein natürlich nicht so ein
glück hab ich dich es hört sich total
behindern an es ist aber wirklich so als
ich dachte was die die hürde die wir
erforschen wollten wir da vorne
es ist wirklich so man wenn man weiß
okay ich schneide dann dann sag ich
jetzt mal was wieso ich bin jetzt
runtergefallen ok cool
dann atmet man erstmal durch gucken ob
die face käme alles stimmt ob ihr alles
irgendwie gut zusammen gelingt ist ob
alles in richtung stimmt doch alles noch
läuft dann nimmt man weiter auf also so
ist es bei mir und deswegen sind
raw-dateien wenn ich schneide bei mir
auch meistens im gegen die immer so weiß
ich nicht roland 35 bis 40 minuten lang
war ich dann halt einfach so ein best-of
herausnehmen und auch zwischendurch echt
ultra lange pausen machen
die lichtung jahren das hat mich dieses
mal dieses lightning drin ich weiß es
gerade gar nicht brightness wie mobbing
performance wellen
lightning ok sieht viel besser aus
und dann finde ich ist einfach so man
wenn man sich daran gewöhnt dass man
schneidet dann kommt man davon nicht weg
für ein video und ich hab jetzt echt
hier vor schon einfach mal so minecraft
aufgenommen survival games dass ich
schon wieder gelöscht habe einfach mal
nur um zu gucken ob ich es hinkriege
uncut aufzunehmen weil wirklich unter
den folgen von diesem let's play sehr
viele geschrieben haben hey luca
normalerweise jetzt aber denkt abgesetzt
aber so hey luca wenn du jetzt schon
dieses letzte machst was ja echt so
mittlerweile main kanal geht ja derzeit
so in die richtung okay wir ich mach mer
real life so einfach das worauf ich bock
hab ich möchte hier mal ganz gut dass
wir offen machen so dass wir den so ein
bisschen miteinander verbunden haben
jedes plötzlich weiterstadt jetzt
bescheuert an aber ich finde ich das
schön wenn wir hier so einfluss haben
das ist natürlich irgendwie verkrüppelt
aber anstatt dass er so eine komische
bindung kacke da wird bleibe ich weiß
nicht aber sein
also wäre ich brauche eine höhle ich
weiß nicht wo die ware in der ich
letztes mal war dann würde ich mich
gerne mal runter gehen bin ich ja fast
gestorben
aber um beim thema zu bleiben ich hab
das aufgenommen um einfach zusehen ok
krieges hin hab es einigermaßen
hingekriegt habe jetzt gesagt ja komm
ich nehme jetzt einfach auf ist es
gerade 18 20 hier bei mir und ich bin
gestern aus belgien wiedergekommen gegen
tumore land wenn ihr wollt dass ich euch
ein bisschen sage ok wat humor denn das
ist ein festival in boom in belgien bei
brüssel ist das und es sind so viele
witzige sachen passiert also ich war
auch davon
ich war mit einem freund oder freundin
da und die beiden haben ihr handy
verloren die haben ihr bargeld verloren
mir wird zum glück nichts geklaut aus
einer deutschland flagge
wir waren da auch noch zusammen mit
daggi und ihrem freund eugen und damit
denen dann noch gefeiert und so und das
war echt alles ultra coole ist dann halt
einfach richtig viele witzige sachen
passiert die ich witzig fand die andere
vielleicht nicht so witzig fanden aber
es war lustig deswegen hatte ich gedacht
morgen einfach mal ein video darüber
okay gut ich bin von der vorne runter
gegangen um zu sehen dass hier die höhle
direkt ist aber gut gehen wir direkt
rein da haben wir direkten creeper alles
klar alles da könnt ihr euch
leckerbissen dankeschön so die schleuder
ich mal direkt wieder nach hinten ich
auch und den keeper auch wieder wenn man
hier wieder direkt auf den körper der
sport und die bei die zombies or crack
pipe du bist auch direktor
da hatte ich halt gedacht morgen mal in
dem video darüber zu reden so von warum
warum sie denn so viele monster gott das
war ja auch typisch diese version damals
das einfach mal so gremmels am weg
blockiert hat ja also das wollte sagen
wollte morgen im video mal darüber reden
wieso jetzt gestern kein video kam warum
wir es so spät warum ich erst so spät
zurückgekommen bin hier nach hause ich
war nämlich auch irgendwie ich hatte
irgendwie erst gestern um 22 uhr zeit
und ich wollte dann kein video mehr
hochladen sondern ich will allgemeinheit
er so in die richtung gehen okay nicht
mehr täglichen video sondern vielleicht
alle zwei tage aber nehmt mich dann
nicht direkt bar an gott und direkt
wieder einen zombie ich wollte da gar
nicht so krass runterspringen was ist
das denn hierfür eine krasse höhle
schaffen jetzt wohl in diesem teil noch
diamanten zu finden hier wenn ich immer
so durch rasche ich weiß jeder ist sonst
so yeah ich mach skript mining von den
krassen minecraft leuten auf youtube
aber halt einfach schöner wenn man
irgendwie so durch eine höhle so
durchläuft und ich das dann mal so alles
anschaut
so ok [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] breit
okay ich hab da noch den weg frei
gemacht gut geht bitte alle weg den
creeper wenn ich jetzt auch gar nicht so
schlimm wenn einfach mal die luft
springen würde
so aber den tätig als erster und jetzt
geben wir hier aufs gerät was wir wo
haben
ich möchte dieses versteckt sie der
sonne und ändernden scheiße ok erstmal
das gerät den element dass ich da hinten
mal stehen
nee also wobei stehen geblieben ich
wollte mehr in die richtung gehen so ja
okay von sieben tagen der woche leid ich
dann vielleicht fünf tage was hoch so
dass ich einfach zwei drei tage pause
habe
dazwischen weil ich derzeit echt von der
uni und allen möglichen anderen sachen
gerade meinem leben abgehen zeitlich
nicht hinkriege jeden tag was
hochzuladen kann diese höhle vielleicht
mal endlich mich immer nach unten führen
wohlwollen diamanten sind ich habe auch
nichts zu essen außer dieses komische
rotten flesh
ich weiß auch gar nicht ich habe es
immer noch nicht verstanden was der sinn
von rotem fleisch ist also wie soll denn
diese fakih musik an musik auf
entwickelte easy und hab ich das auch
normal gehabt er wenig den bescheuert es
waren alle einstellen dass sie das hatte
ich auch nicht auf 88 stehen eigentlich
88 stehen 88 stehen wie verrückt oh gott
alter wieder dahinkommen skelette ach du
heilige kaká so
noch lang laufen hier unten will
eigentlich nur wieder hoch und ging wie
diamanten finden das ist das a
der ist sich schon mal ein bisschen
offener hieraus also wie gesagt ich
laufe lieber ein bisschen langsam durch
dabei schon mal sehe ich glaube ich
gerade da habe ich mir schon den weg
hoch gebaut oder an die das einfach nur
lava budget blöd bekommst du nicht lange
warten wir denn hier
zwei jungs drei creeper also nichts
gegen euch aber schon irgendwie was
gegen das kann doch nicht wahr sein
hey guck mal live
fällt dir was was zum fich warum
was haben sie denn alle tot
also ich habe die ganze zeit ein zombie
atelier wäre aber hier ist einfach
keiner
ach da ist auf maximal 450
ich höre schon wieder hinten stellt auf
mich schießen habe ich weiß auch wieder
nicht von boeing
das ist einfach weil man nicht ob tief
eindringt und nicht dieses lightning
dieses bessere und ich will das ja auch
nicht auf komplett bereitstellen weil
die das ja wieder dann so sehr pussy
heftes wisst ihr ich brauche es jetzt
auch hier einfach mal zu weil das
braucht man ja nicht gut wie toll ich zu
gebaut habe nee also ich war gut das ist
halt das problem weswegen ich
hauptsächlich schneide weil ich einfach
nicht auf den punkt kommen kann wer gut
luca gut wenn ich normal rede
wenn ich das nicht schneider dann kann
ich mich überhaupt nicht irgendwas
konzentrieren ich leuchte auch überall
mal ganz kurz hier mit fakten aus also
ich komme jetzt mal ganz kurz auf den
punkt der punkt warum ich schneide ist
einfach warum ich jetzt nicht mehr
schneiden werden diese liste ist einfach
weil ich so was vermisst habe ein video
wo ich nicht primär darauf aus bin ok
ich muss die katze möglichst so setzen
dass alles super ist und alle zufrieden
und alles irgendwie so witzig so as far
as possible
ich höre die ganze zeit so scheiß
zombies hier das faktisch hat übel ab
sondern ich will mich jetzt einfach mal
in diesem let's play zumindest darauf
konzentrieren dass ich im fokus mehr
darauf setzte okay ich laber mit euch
und konzentriere mich aufs spiel und
nicht darauf so oh mein gott ich werde
angegriffen und auch gott
ich dachte wenn diamanten war uns aber
nicht ich muss mal ganz kurz hier weg
hier sind gerade ein paar böse monster
hinter mir
so hoffen wir hier lang so 20 euro dass
ich mich komplett verlaufen werde hier
lang
hier ist das ende okay denn von da
hinten einer kommt bin ich total amanos
also das ist quasi so der der hauptpunkt
weil ich das ein bisschen vermisst habe
einfach nur normal zu reden und sich
nicht so darauf zu konzentrieren
ich bin auf dem fuß am programm ich habe
mir übrigens einen kaktus gekauft ihr
schaut mal der ist echt meine ganze
wohnung ist eigentlich voll mit kunst
pflanzen läuft hier so gucken was ich
eigentlich in dem cut gemacht aber wenn
man jetzt wohnungs eigentlich voll mit
kunst pflanzen kaktus gekauft und dachte
mir halt so und jetzt kümmere ich mich
ein bisschen um den eigentlich ganz cool
ja ich weiß nicht ich habe schon tausend
mal gesagt was der grund dafür ist und
da seht ihr ich komme einfach nicht auf
den punkt der grund ist halt einfach
ganz simpel ich habe es vermisst einfach
so zu reden und nicht zu wissen okay ich
schneide danach noch einmal anderthalb
stunden video in dem quasi die hälfte
raus es geht natürlich trotzdem noch
weiter runter hier in beide richtungen
what the [ __ ] und jetzt hier wieder lang
alter freund ist nicht was ist das für
eine höhle
hier ist auch so viel kohle ich werd ich
weiß ich werde nachher wieder sagen oh
gott hätte ich mal mehr kohle person
shit deswegen komme ich nehme es ein
bisschen hier von muttermilch zumindest
weiß ich bin hier runter gegangen
also hier ist noch ein bisschen reisen
ja also das ist mal zu der sache
deswegen freunde dieses system wird
erstmal vorerst nicht mehr geschnitten
sondern wird dann quasi so ein video
achso hier bin ich sondern wird dann so
quasi das video auf einem kanal bleiben
in der woche wo ihr will ist okay wenn
ihr luca uncut sehen wollt und minecraft
sehen wollt dann ist es etwas umgefallen
in meiner wohnung dann wisst ihr halt
dass es dieses video ist so also dann
könnt ihr dieses video hier als sehen so
wenn ihr versteht was meine kann also
und die zweite sache die ich sagen
wollte war
das wird dann habe ich schon gesagt dass
deswegen gestern kein video kam war ich
erst so spät wieder da war
die story was macht er denn sehr dunkel
auch alles in dieser blöden version
die story dahinter ist einfach wir waren
total fertig nach dem letzten tag und
der letzte tag das erzähle ich euch
morgen im video
ich hatte eigentlich und hotel gebucht
plus tumore land ticket habe aber
irgendwie meine freunde verloren und wir
dann auf einmal zu dream will gelaufen
und dream will müsste wissen ist ein ort
wo man kämpft bei tom rowland und dafür
braucht man halt ein gesondertes ticket
und das habe ich halt eigentlich nicht
nachhaltigen gelaufen zusammenstand der
so lost and found hieß und da konnte man
halt bot afag da ist der krippe als ich
dachte ich habe keinen krieg aber direkt
neben mir gesehen als den frauen stand
gelaufen hat den halt so gesagt so diese
jahr luca du kannst du nur hingehen wenn
du wirklich irgendwann verloren hast und
ich dann nur so ja ich hab meine freunde
verloren so es gibt nichts schlimmeres
zu verlieren so das habe ich ihnen
angeguckt nehme ich glaube nicht
schon wieder überall zombies und ich
will nicht weiter nach oben ich bin
weiter nach unten ich will endlich mal
diamanten haben hier was finde ich pilze
schön und hier war es auch einfach schon
hier sieht gut aus
das sieht sehr gut aus sorgt dann wäre
ich jetzt mal ganz kurz die so ein blog
reinsetzen dass so ein bisschen aus
leuchtet uns das anschauen kann also
dementsprechend weil ich nicht kannte
werden die partner auch länger also
dieser party geht jetzt gerade auch
schon irgendwie 14 15 minuten oder hier
kommt noch mal was heraus so die werden
dann halt so auf die 20 minuten zu gehen
einfach dass ihr so weil sich halt echt
so viele wo kommt denn je nicht wasser
raus weil sich also viele beschwert
hatten ja luca du machst nur noch an
cathomas nur noch bekannte videos also
das wird doch noch hauptsächlich main
kanal bleiben aber dieses video wird
also diese am dienstag kommt immer was
nicht anders so haben wir beendet das
thema und deswegen bald erste spiel zu
hause weil wir halt total fertig waren
vom tag schaue ich hab das taxi halt
nicht das shuttle halt geprüft zum hotel
für jeden tag
ich hab das halt dementsprechend mich
bekommen von der zeit her und wollte
dann halt irgendwie zu green begehen
darstellen was dann lief in welcher
dieses handy gleicher dieses ticket
nicht hatte richtig dumm einfach und das
kann ich euch dann als morgen erzählen
aber deswegen kamen jetzt am montag also
gestern kein video man alter gold ok
gold ist schon mal schön weiß man nicht
was damit machen soll
aber diamanten werden doch vielleicht
auch mal ganz was schönes oder also ich
weiß ja nicht
naja vielleicht solltest einfach in der
nächsten folge erst der fall sei nicht
erst mal dass goldman daraus kann man es
ja diese rails machen und dann will ich
irgendwann noch so eine rennstrecke
bauen oder so ich weiß noch nicht wie
lange es heiß her geht also ehrlich
gesagt so wenn ich dann irgendwann keine
lust mehr darauf hoffen kommt einfach
nicht mehr also aber freunde es dauert
erst mal noch ein bisschen so ist
anstrengend nur ein stück zu labern
locker habe ich die ganze zeit immer nur
geschnitten weil es
leichter ist als es dauert im ich komme
da überhaupt nicht klar was ist das
finde ich ihre höhle
das ist halt so krass in dieser version
sind gibt's lapislazuli okay ich denke
wir nähern uns gerade so ein bisschen in
diamanten
das sieht aber sehr danach aus als wenn
das ganze hier schon wieder vorbei ist
ja wow cool 30 millionen jahre gelaufen
um lapislazuli zu finden
ich meine locker liegen hier auch
irgendwo diamanten aber ich will mich
jetzt nicht durch irgendwelche wende
buddeln so dafür müsste man dann
schneiden weil ich so was nicht antun
will
aber weißt du was ich meine hier ist bin
ich den ganzen tag weg gelaufen
ach gott und jetzt ist er da oben auch
noch kommt die fa
danke tschüss was haben wir hier noch
nie hier ist noch ein weg hallo mama
nach da unten gibt's auch noch lang wie
gott überall mensch da ich sehe jedoch
keinen bogen dadurch zwinkern hier
du bist tot irgendwo hier müssten
nochmal die an einer wand klatschen oder
so alter wollen diese ganzen skelette
mich verarschen solches erst ein
bisschen hunger dings hier
ich fresse ein bisschen hunger das auch
stark hey stelle mich nicht ich fress
hier gerade peter becker so weiter
machen zombie
ich meine wenn ihr schon so viele top
sind
freunde es ist wenn die diamanten nur so
von erhöhen struck lava einfach lava
kleine diamanten
ja gut
was soll ich dazu sagen minecraft hast
mich welcher höhe bin ich mit 320 ps es
gibt doch die amateure 26 oder so oder
dann dann können auch hier vielleicht
mal welche auftreten
ich weiß auch nicht was ich mit
diamanten jetzt machen soll weil ich
dann noch einmal richtig kämpfen war
oder so aber es wäre schon schön oder
also allein diamanten zu besitzen wäre
schon schön
also ich meine diamanten zu besitzen
eine schönheits keine diamanten zu
besitzen die man auch noch ab hier so
zur freude wir sind bei 19 minuten in
dem partner oder 18 oder irgendwie so
ich möchte am liebsten im nächsten
wochen creeper weg da fekter nein weg
weg weg so hallo hier bin ich und die da
oben ist da ist eine spinne ach schön
gut und gerne noch den spinnen spanner
meine damen und herren so ohne eine
schlucht
die schlucht mit lava bild mit skelett
ok ok freund ich mache das jetzt hierzu
habe hier alles irgendwie mehr oder
weniger ausgeleuchtet ich hab noch nicht
alles ausgeleuchtet weil die höhle
einfach unnormal krass ist also man kann
über langlaufen okay hier ist alles
ausgleichen kann ich jetzt mal stehen
beim block ich mich jetzt aus freunde
und jetzt würde ich sagen ich beende an
dieser stelle das video freunde das war
mein erstes richtiges anker video seit
locker mehr als einem jahr
deswegen wollte ich einfach mal wieder
testen ich bin in der roda teils bei 21
minuten gerade also das video sei
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen kürzer
innerhalb minute oder so weiter zu
beginn ein bisschen geschnitten habe
aber ja wenn es euch gefallen hat lasten
bewertung da also dieses projekt jetzt
gegen dienst da kommt ein anteil
minecraft als manager said paul ryan